- So there're a few questions
that have already been
sent in, that I wanted to touch upon,
and one of 'em is how
often should I practice?
And...
It kinda depends on how
soon you're taking the test,
it depends on what your schedule is,
what your score goals are, how many times
you've taken the test, but, really,
it makes sense, the more you
do it, the better you get,
and if you make that
commitment to yourself,
to improving the score, your
scores will keep on rising,
and on the Official SAT Practice
you basically have what you need
to be working with real practice questions
created by the College
Board, and by Khan Academy
with College Board's help, and,
three a times a week for
30 to 60 minutes each
would be a good amount to study.
If you're taking the test next month,
you might wanna do an hour
to three hours a week.
If you're waiting until
March to take the test,
waiting until May to take the test,
that changes the equation.
The best thing you can do
is to take a full-length
practice test, and see where you stand,
and let the system tell
you what level you're at.
There's level two, there's level three,
there's level four, if
you start at level two,
you do all the level two questions,
you look at what you've done wrong,
you learn from the solution steps,
and you'll find your way to
level three, and to level four,
and you'll gain points,
and it makes it fun,
so, let me see.
A very important thing is
to remember that the test
is four hours long.
That's if you take the essay,
and it's regular timing
on the test, is about four hours long,
and, if you just walk
in there on test day,
and you've never done
a four-hour-long test,
it's gonna come as a rude awakening, and,
so I urge you, if you are taking the test,
in October, let's say, to
take one to two full-length
practice tests on Saturday morning,
just like test day,
and see what it's like,
see what it's like to write
this essay after three hours
of multiple-choice testing.
It's intense.
Another question that's come
up is, what's a good score?
And I think that it's important
for everybody to realize
that your SAT score's
just one very small part
of your college application.
Colleges are interested in your grades,
colleges are interested in recommendations
from your teachers,
colleges are interested
in the extracurriculars, the
way that you spend your time,
job experience, internships,
any leadership positions
that you might've done, any
kind of, what makes you tick,
what are your interests,
what are your passions?
So your grades are more
important than your SAT score.
Your recommendations are important.
And, so, just remember
that that's critical,
and the SAT is an
important element to show
your college admissions
officers, just how ready you are.
Just where you fit in
the range of students
who have applied to this school before.
So, depending on the colleges
that are on your list,
you will have a different range of scores
that you can discover, by which I mean,
there's a 25th percentile,
and there's a 75th percentile
of scores of students
that have been accepted
into any college, and you
can find that information
on BigFuture.org, you
can look up the school,
you can use college guides,
and it's a statistic
that every college makes available,
and that's 25% of the
students applied with a score
who were offered admission
with a score below
the 25th percentile range,
and 75% of the students
had scores that were, so somebody scored,
if you're in the 75th percentile,
that is better than 75% of
the people who applied, so,
and who get offered admission,
so, what you do is you
create a range, you say,
you look at all the 25th percentile scores
for the colleges in your list,
you look at the 75th percentile scores
and you use that as an indicator
for what you think you should do,
and what your target should
be for your SAT score,
and, I recommend that if
you make a reach goal,
to reach for that 75th percentile,
then, your SAT score will
definitely check the boxes
for that college, and you don't need to,
and you can probably move
on to another critical part
of your admissions profile,
which would be your grades,
you really want to have
really solid grades
in junior year, sophomore
year, and on senior year,
or, other elements, like,
pursue your passions,
get leadership positions, if you can,
or participate, make a
contribution to your school,
is an important element of
your college admissions too.
Another question that has come up
is, what do we need to bring on test day?
And, you can find that information
on Official SAT Practice,
you can also find it on
the College Board website,
I think College Board, or Khan Academy,
the team who's watching right now,
hopefully will be posting
where those links are,
but you can just go find out
that information right there.
Honestly, there's so much
information available
on the Khan Academy, Official SAT Practice
product, so, we have, the
Tips and Strategies section
is not just tips and
strategies, there's a lot of
the changes that have
been made to the SAT,
what to expect on test day,
what are acceptable calculators,
there's information on
College Board about that,
what are the different question types,
what are the different
lengths of the sections,
what's a raw score, what's a scaled score,
all this information is
on Official SAT Practice
in Khan Academy.
Let me see.
I'm gonna go to, let's see, let's see
what kinda questions I have here.
Is there prep for PSAT?
This is coming in from
Samman, and, let's see, yeah,
the PSAT and the SAT are the
skills that both of those tests
test, are the same.
The Official SAT Practice is
also applicable for the PSAT,
because the tests are so
close in what the content is,
what the skills are that it's testing you.
The practice schedule feature allows you
to also set a schedule
leading up to the PSAT,
and we also have an official PSAT
that you can download
off the site as well.
Another question has come in.
How should we practice
and tackle the essay?
Great question.
The essay is an amazing,
they've changed the essay,
and the essay right now is an assignment
that you would see any
college-level English course,
or History course, and
it is testing how well
you can analyse evidence,
and understand how an author
is using different devices,
different writerly devices,
to persuade the audience
of his or her point
that she or she is making.
We have tips and strategies
around helping you with this,
we're somewhere in development,
we also have full-length essays
with scoring for each exam
that you can download and work on,
and if you go to the essay section now,
you'll see that there're a
couple of relatively new entries
into the Tips and Strategies.
One is called Unpacking
the SAT Essay Prompt,
which is adapted from the
official SAT Study Guide,
basically, it takes apart
the prompt, and says,
this is what you're supposed to do.
You're not supposed to just
say what the author is saying,
you're not supposed to
reiterate, to say again,
what the point is, you're not paraphrasing
the whole document, or the whole passage.
You are, if we go there, you have one part
which is, explain how the
author builds an argument
to persuade the audience.
And so that is something that
there are do's and don't's
that I put in that article.
Consider how the author uses
evidence to support claims.
I make a list, there's a list in there now
of different types of evidence
that you might consider,
that you might look out for,
as you're reading through
the passage.
Consider how the author uses
reasoning to develop ideas,
and connect claims and evidence.
In the article, we
explain what reasoning is,
and how that applies, and how
you might be able to draw out
these elements from the
passage that you're analyzing,
and evaluating.
Consider how the author uses stylistic
or persuasive elements to add
power to the ideas expressed.
So this article is about taking apart
this really dense prompt, and saying,
okay, this is what this means,
this is what it means to you,
when you're sitting there for 50 minutes,
and you need to write a three-page paper,
and how to tackle that,
another really great essay,
that's another article
that's in there now, is,
The SAT Essay, Analyzing a Passage,
in which we take apart, or
examine how one might approach
one of the prompts that is
a real SAT essay prompt,
so I'd say check that out as well.
Let's see.
What else we have here?
How should we practice and
tackle the essay section?
The more you do it, the better you get.
So we're working on adding new features
that may actually enable you
to get your essay graded,
but the best way to do
it is to actually put
pencil to paper, or type an essay in,
and give yourself a timed
scenario to see how you do,
and understand that you
need an introduction,
you need body paragraphs,
and you need a conclusion,
and each of those body paragraphs
is probably going to focus
on an element, so maybe,
let's say, the author is using
a lot of statistics, or data.
You would use that body
paragraph to talk about
how the author uses data and evidence
to support his or her
point, and then you take out
quoted little statistics, or,
paraphrase little statistics,
from throughout the essay,
from throughout the passage,
and put all that evidence
into that body paragraph.
Then you move on to the
second body paragraph,
and you think of another element
that the author is doing,
maybe the author is making the reader feel
afraid of what might happen if...
If they don't turn off
the air conditioner,
and you basically point
out all those little things
in the passage that the author says
to kinda me a little scared
about what might happen
with climate change, if I keep
burning my air conditioner.
So, you take those elements, threads
from different paragraphs of the passage,
and weave them into one body
paragraph in your essay.
So, you kinda work through it that way.
Let's see, another question.
Are we allowed to use graphing
calculators during the SAT,
or only scientific calculators?
This is from Shawn, thanks
Shawn, great question.
There's a full list of acceptable
calculators on SAT.org,
and there's a calculator policy,
you go there under Taking
the Test, on SAT.org.
In general, most graphing
calculators are permitted,
so, just check that out.
Ordinarily, with a calculator,
you don't really need it,
and if you find yourself doing
really lengthy calculations
in your calculator, the chances are,
you might've missed something,
so I just wanna say,
be cautious about when you
pick up your calculator,
obviously, there's a section of the SAT
that you're not allowed
to use a calculator,
but even when you are using a calculator,
it's the calculator
section, that doesn't mean
that the first thing you do
is type the numbers you see
in the question into the calculator.
You wanna take a step back,
you wanna say to yourself,
hold on, what does the question want,
what is the question telling
me, what's my game plan here?
And then you decide whether you need
the calculator or not, to do that.
Let's see.
Another question.
How can I reset my skill level
so I can practice the
lower skill levels of math?
The answer is, well, you can't.
The Official SAT Practice
doesn't allow you
to reset your skill level,
because it's a reflection
of where you are.
If you wanna review things
from a lower skill level,
then, you can go to the review tab
at the top of Official SAT Practice,
and look at the questions
again, that you missed.
Let's see.
Another question.
I'm a junior, but I am not
taking Pre-Calc and AP Calc,
but can I still really do well on the SAT,
through Khan Academy SAT practice?
And the answer is, absolutely, man!
Or, whoever you are!
Absolutely!
The best way that you can
prep for the SAT right now,
is to go on Khan Academy,
and do a diagnostic,
see how you do.
If you get the questions
wrong, that is okay.
The system will send you
to practice those skills
that you're not strong enough in yet,
to get those questions right.
The key to doing well is to start early,
and just keep on getting familiar
with the skills you need on the test.
You also can watch videos on any concept
you haven't learned yet,
so, that isn't just an
Official SAT Practice, if you don't find
what you need there, then
head on out to Khan Academy,
go to the subjects, and get some!
Get some amazing videos
and articles and exercises
to help you strengthen your skills
in the areas that you need.
Let's see, another one.
What about book
recommendations and strategies
for the reading part?
This is from Haya.
There's always one passage
from the US founding documents,
and the great conversations
that they've inspired
through the years, women's suffrage,
there are all sorts of
debate about slavery,
debate about the way that
the Constitution was drafted.
The...
This is bumping around.
Other passages included are classic
and contemporary literature, a
passage about social science,
and two science passages.
If you wanna practice for the
reading section of the test,
look at the strategies that
are in Tips and Strategies,
on the Official SAT Practice.
If you're trying to, really, just build up
your reading fluency, then,
read the New York Times,
read the Washington Post,
read the Chicago Tribune,
read the LA Times, read Newsweek,
read content, read stories,
that are at the level
that the SAT is at, but, you
don't need to do that now,
you should jump in to
Official SAT Practice,
and look at those passages.
There are lots of sample
passages there to try out,
and, if you get questions
wrong, it's no big deal,
nobody's gonna look at your results,
nobody's gonna look at your practice,
you don't need to let
anybody in except you,
and, so, go for it!
Let's see.
I have exhausted all the
exercises, what should I do now?
We continually are adding new exercises,
we're adding more writing
and language exercises
this week and next, we're
adding more reading passages
this week and next, but, congratulations
if you've done all of this
stuff, you've done tons of work,
and I hope that you've seen results.
The thing that I wanna emphasize here,
is that if you've done the passages,
and you've gotten questions
wrong, what you should do
is go and pretend you've
never seen them before.
You shouldn't look at the answer and say,
oh, that's the answer, I guess
I'll try another question,
right?
Every question is this opportunity
to learn about that type
of question, and say,
like, what do I have to
do differently next time
when this sort of question comes my way?
And when you're using the
review tab the right way,
every one of those questions you missed
from the moment you started
using the Official SAT Practice,
this will be able to, you'll
be able to say to yourself,
okay, this one went wrong, this
is why that answer is right,
this is why the answer I chose was wrong,
I think I got it now, and
then you try another passage.
Let's see.
I have another question from Erphan,
what can I do if I feel like I'm stuck,
and not making progress?
Great question, can be super frustrating.
I would love to know from you whether it's
the reading section you're
having trouble with,
the writing and language section
you're having trouble with,
or whether it's math, math,
I'd say, watch all the videos,
go back into the main Khan Academy site,
and study those math types, if
you've used all the exercises
and done all the problems
in Official SAT Practice.
In the reading, it may be
because of time management,
which we haven't quite talked about yet.
So, time management in
the reading section,
like if you're somebody who's
finding yourself out of time
on the reading section, then
there are things you can do
to build up your score, and in part,
that's realizing that there are
different difficulty levels,
every question is different,
and there are some easy,
there's some easier questions at the end,
at the end of the reading
section, the passage at the end
is not necessarily the hardest passage,
the passage at the end of
the writing and language test
is not necessarily the hardest passage,
so, if you're running out
of time and having to guess
on a passage or two, at the
end of those parts of the SAT,
then you should make a real adjustment
to the way that you manage your time,
and there's details about
that in Tips and Strategies,
we have a couple new articles
there, about time management,
and there're also a couple
great articles there now
about active reading strategies
that will help you really
engage with the passage
in a more active way,
in a more focused way,
and also, help you not choose
choices that look good,
just because they look good, right?
The answer choices are
created to look good, right?
So, the best way that you can move forward
with so many of the questions
in the reading test,
is, have some idea of
what you're looking for
before you start looking, right?
So what does that mean?
That means that, if you
have question that's like,
the primary purpose of paragraph three
can best be described
as, what you should do
is not just read the choices right then.
If you're reading the choices right then,
then you might just choose
one that looks good, right?
What you should do instead
is take a moment, and say,
okay, what is this question asking?
What is paragraph three doing?
What is the purpose of paragraph three?
You go back to paragraph
three, you look at it,
you say it in your own words, you say,
oh, paragraph three is
supplying evidence to support
the author's point about...
Arctic tern migration, or
something, and then you say, okay,
that's what it's doing,
and then you go back
to the choices then, and you say, okay,
I'm looking for supporting point about
Arctic tern migration, and at that point,
you know what you're looking for,
you're in control of the question,
you're in control of
what you're looking for,
and at that point, the wrong answers
kinda disqualify themselves,
because they don't really
tell you what you thought
you were looking for.
And this is a lot about trusting yourself,
and there's more about
that in the article,
in Tips and Strategies.
So that's what I'd say about that.
And, let's see.
Another question.
If you have good grades but
don't have a great SAT score,
does that affect your chances
of getting into a good school?
I answered that a little
bit earlier, in a way,
I addressed that a little bit earlier.
And remember, the SAT is just one part
of your college application,
and I would encourage you
to check out BigFuture.org
to explore the colleges
that might be a good fit
for you based on your GPA,
and your tests scores and your interests,
but, grades are really important.
Grades demonstrate that
you work hard in school.
If you have great grades
and your SAT isn't so good,
you certainly aren't the
first person in the world
to have this problem, that
have like test-taking anxiety,
you freeze up when you're,
like, they're on a timed test,
if you had a choice between being somebody
who had awesome grades and
a kind of mediocre score
on the SAT, and somebody who had
mediocre grades, and an
awesome score on the SAT,
I would much rather be the first student,
because, if you have mediocre grades
but an awesome SAT score,
as admission officer,
I may say, like, this
student is an underachiever,
this student isn't working hard,
what's going on here,
there's a weird story here.
But if you get great grades and you have
great recommendations, then yes,
you don't necessarily need
to have an amazing SAT score,
if you look at those score
ranges, 25th to 75th percentile,
if you have a score down
to the 25th percentile,
25% of the people who were
offered admission to that school
had scores lower than that,
so, I hope that makes sense,
if you have questions, you can ask 'em,
and we'll try to answer
'em, relating to that,
if that doesn't make sense.
Question, okay, let's
see, I have registered
for the October 1st exam.
What would be the best practice plan
from now til October?
Great question.
Maybe there're a bunch
of you in this boat.
I'd say that you should
take a diagnostic test
as soon as possible,
and, or link your exam,
your most recent SAT exam, or your PSAT,
to Official SAT Practice, and then create
a practice plan from there, and the system
will also create one for
you that you can customize,
so it's just, oh, you wanna
do eight hours a week,
how about Monday, Tuesday,
Thursday, from five to seven,
and you can tweak that,
and move it around,
and decide what it is that you wanna do,
what you can commit to.
That's a great start.
It depends on how much time you have.
The more you do it, the better you get,
and, I would say that taking
one practice test soon,
and planning to take another
full-length practice test
in a week or two before the test,
and then, take the time, after
you take that practice test,
to really dissect it, to take apart
every question you missed, and say, okay,
what happened here?
Is this a percentages question?
Is this a quadratics question?
And the thing is that
that work is done for you
by Official SAT Practice.
So, if you get information
into the system,
the system will tell
you what you should do,
and it will take as much
time as you can give it.
But I'd say a minimum,
four weeks schedule,
if you wanna move your score 100 points,
which is fairly ambitious
but totally possible,
then you wanna put in, I've
seen students hit the books
super hard, and raise their
score 200 points, 300 points.
That's an exception, but you
go in, and you log the time,
and, if you have comments or questions,
as you're using the product,
put 'em in the comments,
put it in the questions,
put it in the tips section
of every one of the articles
in Tips and Strategies,
and we'll try to address
your questions and concerns
in due course.
Let's see.
When is the last SAT test that I can take
before the usual deadline
of college applications?
Great question.
The usual deadline is, a lot of colleges
have different deadlines,
some of them have January 1st,
some of them have January
15th, early decision deadlines
are sometimes at the
beginning of November,
beginning to middle of November,
and, early decision, early
action, the recommendation,
we recommend that you take the test,
October 1st is really the last one to meet
the early deadlines, the
November and December tests
are fine for your later deadline,
so if it's a January 15th
or January 1st, November, December tests
are gonna work out
fine, and you'll be able
to send those scores to those schools.
Let's see.
Is the SAT going to be
harder than last year's SAT?
Okay, what carries more
weight, the ACT or SAT?
Two amazing questions.
Okay.
Is the SAT harder than it was last year?
Totally different tests.
In some ways, yes, in some ways, no.
It's kind of a moot point,
meaning that it doesn't matter
whether it's harder or easier,
because you can't take
the old SAT anymore,
the new SAT is the SAT
now, and some students find
SAT more challenging,
some students find the ACT
more challenging, you can't know
which one you're gonna do better on
until you take a
full-length practice test.
What carries more weight, ACT or SAT?
As far as I know, there's
not a single college
that prefers one test or the
other at this moment in time.
So, that may have been
true, it might've been true
five, 10, 15 years ago,
the word on the street,
the rumors have had it
that Midwestern colleges
prefer ACT, and colleges
on the coasts prefer SAT,
that is not true anymore.
Both are accepted by all colleges, and so,
there's no reason to try
to game it or second guess
which college, which one would prefer,
and you can verify this by calling
any college admissions office.
Try them both out.
Let's see.
Would I recommend practicing
more rather than studying?
Interesting.
Practicing versus studying,
I think it's important
not to just keep on taking practice tests,
you don't just take practice
test after practice test
after practice test, without taking time
between each practice test to say, like,
okay, what do I learn?
Go back, look at any question
that you missed, and say,
okay, why did I miss that?
Was it a careless error?
Could I have gotten this?
What could I have done differently?
And, so...
So I just wanna say, don't
just take practice test
after practice test.
After you take a practice test,
find out what you need to study.
Find out what you need to work on,
and you can use Official
SAT Practice as a resource.
Our goal here is to get
the world's best test prep,
and that's a tall order,
but I think we're doing it,
and it's super exciting
to be a part of this team,
and part of this movement, really,
to make all of this information,
all these tips, all these strategies,
all this real practice questions,
and personalized practice,
available to anybody, for free.
Let's see.
Other questions, let's see,
I'll maybe take a couple more,
running a little over, but this is fun.
In what grade should I start preparing?
Really tough question, I would say,
you're preparing for
college your whole life,
and so, you should be doing
your best in your school,
you should be challenging yourself,
you should be challenging
yourself to read books,
to read articles, to
do your best in class,
and if you're doing that, and
you're challenging yourself
in school, you are preparing for the SAT.
Now, if it comes to, like, when do I,
okay, okay, I get that,
Dave, when do I start using
Official SAT Practice on Khan Academy?
Six months is plenty, but
it depends, for most people.
It depends on what is the
gap you're trying to close
with your scores.
If you have...
If you're trying and you have
a PSAT from sophomore year,
'cause some high schools
administer the PSAT sophomore year.
If you've done that, and you're like,
oh, I need to raise my score
300 points, 400 points,
I still wouldn't hit Official
SAT Practice very hard
until like six months out.
But you can take practice tests.
You can be using Khan Academy,
and do those questions,
and try to fill in whatever holes or gaps
in your comprehension there are in math.
You should take the PSAT
sophomore or junior year,
and then, in your junior year,
you start spending more time doing it.
Maybe the summer before junior year,
if you're gonna be super
slammed junior year
with sports or work or extracurriculars,
or just, you have a
really tough course load,
it may make sense to do a little practice,
take another practice test
the summer before junior year.
When is the best time to take the SAT?
Let's see.
Most students take the SAT
in the spring of junior year,
and then again in the
fall of their senior year,
and that's a good schedule,
the only exception
I might ever add to that is that,
if you take a practice
test, and you're like,
oh my gosh, my score is
amazing, this is totally fine,
I wanna get it out of
the way, then, congrats,
and you could maybe do it earlier,
and take it January or
March of junior year,
but most people, you're
still learning more and more,
throughout junior year,
you're still learning
through the first couple
months of senior year,
your score's gonna sort
of naturally go up,
so, aim to do your best
spring of junior year.
Okay, another question.
Do we need to memorize
SAT words like before?
And the answer is, no, you don't!
The new SAT is designed to
test what you need to know,
and will be more applicable
to college and life.
One of the big changes of the SAT
from the old format to the new format,
is that the vocabulary section,
the sentence completions,
where you had to, like,
plug in the right word,
and these are words
that you maybe never seen before,
and never expect to see again,
those words aren't on the test anymore,
so you have vocab and context questions
that are words that are much more common,
they might have multiple meanings, like,
like the word discriminate,
which isn't always a bad thing,
discriminating can also mean,
it's a verb to mean, like,
noting subtle differences in something,
the word currency is another
one that jumps to mind, like,
things that are current, that
idea is holding currency,
that means that that idea is current,
it's something that people
are talking about now,
it's not the same as money.
So, recognizing those
different contextual clues
to identify those words is something that
is on the current SAT.
Let's see.
I am, let's see, I'm gonna
take two more questions,
then I'm gonna sign off.
Let's see.
Do you have food or water during the test?
Great question.
You need your desk to be
clear, when you take the test.
You're not allowed to have water there
on the table next to you.
You're not allowed to
have food next to you.
But you can have water in your
bag, underneath your chair,
you can have a sandwich stowed away
for your 10-minute break,
or your 5-minute break,
or your 2-minute break.
These breaks are super
short, and just remember
that if you don't take that opportunity,
get up and stretch, and drink
water, and have a snack,
your blood sugar level's gonna go down,
and you may not be able to
focus as well as you'd like,
going into that third, and
that fourth hour, of the test,
so, bring those snacks, figure
out what those snacks are,
have a good dinner the night before,
have a good breakfast the morning of,
and bring stuff with
you to eat really fast
during the break, so you can
keep your energy level up,
'cause it's a marathon, and you need fuel
as you're going through that marathon.
So, let's see.
There's more advice like
that in Tips and Strategies
section of the Official SAT Practice.
Let's see.
How important is SAT for
international students
interested in studying in the US?
Another amazing question.
It depends on the school.
It depends on where you're applying.
The best thing to do, once
you get that list of schools,
is to actually call the admissions
office at those schools,
and ask them, say, "Hey, I'm
applying internationally,
"here are my grades, here's
a little bit about myself,
"what do you think, do you
want me to take the SAT?"
And the answer is probably, "Yes, we do,"
that's the way that we
measure college readiness,
and it's an indicator that,
you take the ACT or the SAT,
this is a part of your
package, but some may say,
"You know what, it's not critical,"
so, you really just
need to call the school,
and that school's gonna start
creating a folder for you,
that's another important part
of your college applications,
you wanna let the school
know that you really
wanna go there, because the college,
most colleges want to offer places
to students who will accept those places,
and go there gladly, and they wanna fill
their freshman class with
students, their first-year class,
with students who are
super psyched to be there,
so, if you demonstrate
your interest in that way,
then that'll help, that
can do nothing but help,
so make those calls, write
those emails, don't be shy,
because it may raise the chances
that they'll remember you
when they start considering
people's applications.
I'll take one more.
Let's see, one little quick one, okay.
Although the math section
gives you formulas,
which it does, is there anything you think
we should have memorized by
heart when we go into the test?
There are a handful of things,
the two that jump to mind
is that you probably wanna
know your distance formula,
you probably wanna know
your midpoint formula,
you want to know difference of squares,
like x squared minus y squared
factors into x plus y times x minus y,
and you should be making
flashcards for yourself,
if there's a little fact that comes up
with a question you missed
on Official SAT Practice,
change it, sorry, write that down,
and make a little flashcard!
You also wanna be super
fluent with the formulas
that are on the test.
You don't wanna be
looking back and saying,
is circumference pi r squared?
By the way, no, it's not,
circumference is pi d,
and the area of a circle is pi r squared,
those are things that, it's really useful
just have on the tip of your tongue,
if you have to be flipping back and forth,
it's slowing you down, it's
wasting critical energy
that you need in order to do your best.
Okay.
We're gonna wrap it up.
And I'll be back!
Another one little thing I'm gonna say,
is there are new articles in
the Tips and Strategies section
that give you an opportunity
to share your favorite tips
that you might've gotten from wherever,
for tackling the various
parts of the SAT, so,
there's a math share space,
there's a writing and language
share space, there's
a reading share space,
general strategies share
space, and essay share space.
Go there and share!
And that includes any
educators that are watching,
if you work with students,
and you have things
that you know work, and you
wanna share those things
with everybody, then, do it, please do it,
we want everybody to use Khan Academy,
use Official SAT Practice,
and, on that note,
I guess I'll bid you all good night,
and hope to see you again,
right here next time,
take care, thanks for
watching, really appreciate it.
Bye.